samwell tarly is more than just your
average loyal sidekick sure he's loyal
honest and his heart of gold is too nice
for this world but there's more to him
than that in fact Sam might just be the
most important game of Thrones character
of all season sixes finale episode
dropped a giant easter egg seemingly
putting him at the center of everything
oh and in case you weren't aware
spoilers ahead what Sam saw in the
Citadel when Sam Gilly and the baby
finally arrived in Old Town he got his
first look at that jaw-dropping library
and we spotted a special something
lingering above him a spherical
chandelier system that's awfully similar
to the astrolabe that shines in the
show's intro credits that's right the
glowing golden orb that comes into focus
and kicks off every episode had always
seemed like something of a lovely but
unimportant visual before but now that
it's seen hanging in the Citadel's
massive library its purpose might be
getting clearer Sam's Song of Ice and
Fire as pointed out by an article from
TV Guide george RR martin author of the
Song of Ice and Fire novels the show is
based on has long admitted to being
inspired by that other double are our
middle name fantasy legend j.r.r tolkien
and his iconic Lord of the Rings series
Samwell Tarly is thought to be a tribute
to Tolkien's character with the same
name Samwise Gamgee that Sam ended up
being pretty important as he was
ultimately given the task of finishing
the story of the one ring to rule them
all and how it was destroyed by Frodo
those pages if we use Martin has
famously promised that his own story
ending would reflect Tolkien's
bittersweet ending style so will Samwell
Tarly do for the Song of Ice and Fire
what Samwise Gamgee did for those little
guys and the jewelry does he write the
story of jon snow versus the white
walkers at the citadel under the light
of the big golden orb is he the reason
that book 6 missed its damn deadline
research to the rescue forget the fact
that Daenerys Targaryen is on her way to
oust Mad Queen Cersei from the Iron
Throne
and that John has been declared king in
the north and may have earned the
jealous ire of his sister / cousin Sansa
Stark and Littlefinger
those are both battles in the grand
scheme of things the true war of course
will come once the night king figures
out how to get his army of White Walkers
past the wall and Sam's access to old
towns bevy of books may help me find a
more efficient way for people to kill
the undead building a better dragonglass
Sam's killed a white Walker himself with
a dragonglass dagger so he already knows
the strength and resilience of the
enemy's forces and obsidians effect on
them he also knows about the stockpile
of dragonglass in the island of
Dragonstone thanks to the late Stannis
Baratheon but the North's forces are
outnumbered and the walkers are tireless
fast and bloodthirsty so really it might
be on Sam to discover a better way to
defeat those seemingly unkillable forces
of darkness could his good-hearted
nature helped convince Daenerys to lend
her dragons to the cause because that
might be super helpful thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know if you think Sam is as
important as we do